Hi everyone.
Welcome to toxic Google.
My name is Dana Han Klein and today it is my pleasure to welcome Andrew Garfield
for 99 homes.
Okay.
Thank you for joining us today.
Oh,
thank you for having me.
So do you mind telling us a little bit about the film?
Yeah,
sure.
Um,
it's,
um,
the,
the 19 nine in the title is an illusion to the 99%.
I think that was the intention of the filmmaker remain Barany anyway.
And um,
it basically follows the Nash family and the process of being evicted from the
family home that goes back a few generations and the,
the man of the house,
which is somehow this guy,
I'm trying to get his family back into the,
the homestead and the measures that he is forced to take to,
to do that.
Um,
ah,
Gosh.
Yeah.
It's um,
we were talking earlier and it's,
it's a,
it's a true story.
Weirdly,
you know,
it's not based on any specific person.
You know,
Dennis,
Naf doesn't exist in the literal sense,
but I think in a symbolic sense,
he is a representative.
Him and his family are all representative of what so many different families in
our country.
I say our country,
despite my accent,
um,
which kind of betrays the fact that I was born here in California,
in Los Angeles,
so don't challenge.
Um,
so yeah,
so it representative of a struggle that feels pretty endemic in our culture
right now.
Um,
this disparity that we were experiencing,
um,
between the rich and the poor,
the haves and the have nots.
Um,
and I hope,
you know,
the hope is that this film is going to be a small step in the conversation back
towards the knowledge,
the understanding.
We'll just remembering because I think we all,
I mean the Internet and what you guys do here at Google is the perfect example
of connectivity.
While not perfect,
might be an imperfect example of connectivity,
which we'll maybe get into later.
But,
um,
but,
but you know,
just to remember that we all really need each other.
And,
uh,
the system,
the current economic social system that has been created and the culture that's
been created by us that were all willfully participating in on a moment to
moment basis is a system that is setting people against each other constantly.
And,
um,
what Dennis Nash experiences,
the character that I play is that the only way that he can put food in his
child's mouth and put a over his kid's head is if he betrays his fellow man.
If he tramples on his fellow man,
that's a messed up system that I don't like being a part of.
I don't like,
I don't like participating in,
in that culture.
Um,
and like we were talking about,
we got to know each other a little bit earlier and,
uh,
she's really lovely.
Um,
from my,
from my perspective very well,
we both have to say that for the purposes of the cameras,
but I'm nowhere near too.
But,
um,
but we are actively participating by,
by going well.
Yeah,
no.
Yeah.
That's just the way the world works at this point,
isn't it?
Yeah.
The haves have and the have nots stone and the rich are getting richer and the
poor are getting poorer.
What can I do about it?
Well,
or sometimes plenty we can do about it and it gets worse
that we're not even participating.
You know,
we don't know that there's anything do participate in yes.
And therefore does it sort of guilt by ignorance,
you know?
You know,
that's such a,
I love that you said that because it makes me think of different oppressive
regimes that we know through our history.
Like the one that comes to me because of my,
my Jewish ancestry is the Nazi regime.
I think we all know what that regime was about.
Um,
and it was very clearly in oppressive.
you know,
it was like,
you guys are subhuman,
so we're going to exterminate you.
We're just going to do it.
And so,
and we're not sorry.
Um,
the regime that we're under now,
as you just said,
there's this insidious thing where we don't know we are being tricked.
We don't know we're being treated as commodities or as just be a good consumer
and,
and shut the hell up.
Um,
so there's something even more twisted cause it's not like we're going to burn
you in,
in the,
in the gas chamber or you're not annoying but new.
Again,
you know,
we're gonna we're going to gas you and then just bend your body.
We're actually going to slowly starve view and not allow you to access the basic
human needs that you,
that you have.
Well not only that,
but we're going to put this kind of very tempting lifestyle or,
or way to achieve these needs and then just kind of Yank it out.
The American lie.
I mean the American dream.
Um,
no,
I mean as you said,
there's no one dentist and ask,
but there are thousands of dentists,
Nash families or Nash families and this is kind of,
for me,
it was one of the first times where it's like,
yes,
you realize that this is going on at a basic level.
You read the news,
you see whatever.
But this was a way to connect with it.
That was like,
I was so upset and stressed watching this film and I mean,
that is a compliment and that I was like,
oh my God,
I don't know what I would do in this scenario.
And I don't know what would happen.
There was just like such a desperation to the situation they were in that was
just so frustrating to watch as an audience member and be like,
what?
So for,
I mean,
for you,
what was that like when you go,
you kind of go,
yes,
so what are the options?
Right.
It's like
the,
my son starves and I stopped when my mother starves or I become a very active
participant in the,
and I started evicting people myself and justify it.
You know,
that's,
that's one option.
And uh,
and,
and uh,
and then you kind of go,
well,
in order to do that,
I have to not feel,
I have to not look people in the eye.
Because if I look you in the eye as I'm kicking you out of your house,
I'm not gonna be able to live with myself.
If I do happen to catch a glimpse of your eye while I'm doing this,
I've got to go home and I've got to have at least a six pack of beer and a
massive joint and check the hell out.
I've got to numb myself out in order to go back and do it again tomorrow.
Um,
so,
so that was part of my experience and I got to go to Florida and hang out with a
bunch of families and people that this has happened to.
And they are all so devastated and hurt and betrayed.
They've been betrayed by the country.
They've been betrayed by the land,
the promised them a certain basic needs.
And so many of them have alcohol problems and drug problems and have had their
children taken away to foster care and the lives have literally been
destroyed.
Yeah.
From,
from the inside out.
And,
uh,
I got a text from my friend Rick today who's one of who's one of the guys that I
met with.
So it's,
it's still feels very close to me and I'm so glad that he did because it's given
me the
remembering how
the look in these guys' eyes,
the betrayal,
the anger,
the rage,
the cell that leads to this self destruction is,
uh,
something that I hope,
you know,
I'm an actor.
You know,
I'm not going and putting people in homes and building homes and whatever.
I'm an actor.
That's what I'm here to do.
So I hope that this story
is a small little step in the conversation back towards real interconnectedness,
real community,
not Facebook community,
but like being with each other and really like remembering we need each other in
a real way.
And so yeah,
I think,
I think there's definitely a sense of kind of humanity to the story that it
reminds you and it again,
it is,
there's,
there's a ton of moral ambiguity because as you said,
you know,
your character goes through this thing where it's like,
well,
when we all do the same for our families,
you know,
if you were given the choice to save your family at the expense of other people
or you know,
just be one of them,
I think a lot of people would do what he did and,
and kind of compromise their original moral compass.
And I don't think that necessarily the character starts out as a greedy person.
You know,
it's just like self preservation.
But there is kind of an arc where it's like,
well,
what,
how much is just like taking care of yourself and how much is going above and
beyond.
And I think that there's a temptation to,
once we're kind of at a certain level,
just be like,
oh,
well what's,
what's on the other side of that?
You know,
what's,
what's the 1%,
what are they the perfect word.
Yeah.
And so I think for me,
watching the film,
it was,
it was like you,
you did this,
you had this really tough task where it's like,
well,
we want to like you,
but you're also doing things that
we can link to it.
So,
I mean,
was that challenging for you to kind of keep this,
hold on to this kind of core or,
or did you go,
that's where this needs to go and I need to kind of let go of that.
Gosh,
wow.
How do I own so that,
I mean,
we betray ourselves every day.
Um,
I portray myself every day.
I,
I do things that are not in line with who I am every day.
um,
so it's not,
it's not hard to get into small ways,
you know,
I'm not saying like,
I'm going to go,
I haven't murdered anyone,
you know,
in the last 32 years of my life.
But,
uh,
but I played track record,
but you know,
like in small ways,
I compromise myself.
I do things that are not coming from that deep in integrated place.
And,
uh,
because I'm asked to in order to be liked,
in order to be socially acceptable,
in order to be a good boy,
in order to be successful in order to be accepted.
And I think that's right now anyway,
how,
I'm kind of relating to where Dennis is and that question of what do we do,
how would we do,
what would we do in that situation?
And maybe we are already already in that situation or have been and we have made
certain choices that have compromised something deeper and have compromised
someone else,
um,
in a negative way that may be we've been ignoring and not looking at.
And that's the other thing about this,
this film is
it's a part of society and as a part of our culture that we really don't want to
look at.
I've of course,
because who wants to look at people in pain?
It's really hard to do because then we feel empathy and then we feel sad and no
one likes to feel sad.
Although after seeing inside out,
I hopes people start to realize the value of sadness and the beauty of sadness.
Um,
I certainly was reminded of it.
these people saw inside out
these people how can see,
um,
so the,
so,
yeah.
So then,
so then,
and then in feeling all those emotions and feeling that empathy in that
connectedness to your fellow man,
then you go,
Oh shit,
I've got to do something.
That means I've got to quit my job at Google.
That means I'm going to stop being on the line all the time.
That means I've like,
got to live my life
and I'd like deeper way.
How am I going to do that?
Like,
and that's like,
this is just me.
I'm talking about.
I don't ever,
I don't work at Google,
but,
but like,
you know,
it's a challenge.
It's always a challenge too.
It's like,
it's,
it's scary.
It's scary to look at.
So,
but,
but hopefully,
again,
this film is,
is something that we'll,
we'll,
we'll outrage people like,
outraged,
like outrage.
Do I think like it made you incredibly angry that man can be so inhumane to,
to that fellow men.
Yeah.
Um,
so I,
I hope that other people have so many,
everyone sees it just in case they feel the same way and they go,
wait a minute,
how can I do something different?
I think it's,
it's definitely a conversation opener.
It's a reminder because it is something that,
again,
we know what's going on,
but it's not in your face anymore necessarily.
And,
and it's also like,
I don't think there's necessarily an understanding of how it happened,
you know,
we all know it happened vaguely,
but it's like,
oh,
this is,
this is how it actually happens and this is how it affects just somebody who's
not trying to buy a million dollar mansion or whatever.
Just somebody trying to like keep their home.
That's right.
Um,
so what,
so what brought you to the project?
Because it's clearly like a very passionate role for you and it's a tough one.
It was a challenging one,
but I think all these things,
I think as all these things that you're saying,
um,
I feel uncomfortable in the,
in us,
in our culture,
I don't even feel right.
I don't feel,
uh,
happy,
joyous and free.
Let's put it that way,
unless I'm missing a Pixar movie.
Um,
you know,
it's really,
it's,
I find it hard to seek out that very soulful experience in the culture as it
stands.
It,
that doesn't feel like very common when it comes to the center of our culture.
So I have to search a lot and I have to find my own,
my own way to it.
It's,
when I read this,
it was,
it,
it really hit me in this really deep way.
And I got to page thirsty,
which was when my family is evicted and I just was in,
I,
it taught me a part,
like I was just bawling my eyes out and I never,
I'm not,
I was raised in a middle class family.
My parents were working class and they,
and my father reboot the American lie and,
uh,
and was so as beautifully aspirational and wanted to provide a better life for
me and my brother and put better in quotation marks if you didn't know what
those were.
Um,
so what do I know about being evicted?
But I did feel this Willy Loman ish fear pervading the household.
This like what if it all falls away and,
and,
and is this enough,
that thing of like,
what about a bigger house?
What about a bigger thing?
What about a big a Mac?
What about a big,
a big Mac?
What about a big uh,
nuggets?
Oh,
it's the,
would you like fries with that?
And like I don't eat fries but I want them,
well no,
we need them.
You know,
you can,
what is it like a hundred chicken nuggets you can buy now?
The a hundred Doug challenge
that's happened.
This is where we've got to bigger,
more,
more and more,
you know,
and like,
wait,
no,
we had all the,
and all the abundance or the abundance in our culture is being held by this.
Like Rupert Murdoch and Donald Trump and his,
he's saying we don't have any more getting the foreigners out of the country.
We don't have any more while he's holding his billions of dollars.
It's just insane.
It's all this thing.
All this stuff is in the culture.
It's in me.
And I'm just like,
I don't know,
what do I do?
I'm an actor.
I don't know what I'm going to change the world.
But um,
but,
but I read the script and I was like,
well this,
this could be a,
this could be my me doing my bit for the time being and shedding light on a
situation that makes me really,
really sad and really angry and it makes me want to need to do something.
So I act
you're doing like the becoming self deprecating with the whole acting thing.
But um,
you know,
and that's the other thing that the film talks about is that not one person is
going to change the world.
It does not going to,
it's not going to take a fucking stupid,
sorry,
I'm going to take a superhero is not going to come down and change everything.
It's going to be one man.
It's going to be each and every one of us doing our extraordinary thing,
whatever that happens to be,
whether it's gardening,
masonry,
the acting,
you know,
googling stuff.
But it takes everyone to bring their gifts to the culture.
And I think this is something that we've not been reminded of in a long time.
And a community that,
that idea of true,
true community and what that means.
And I think we were talking about this earlier,
right?
She's like,
we are,
we are community that's constantly connected,
but we are not necessarily like connected on a deeper level all the time.
You know,
you know what your friends are doing because they posted about it.
That doesn't mean you asked your friends what they're doing and how they're
doing.
Um,
and I think it's a lot of bits,
like it has to be in your face sometimes because like you said,
we don't want to look people in the eye and feel that.
So we sit and watch a movie instead.
But then we'd go,
Oh man,
like I have to feel all of this and now what do I do with that?
And so,
you know,
it's leading to a conversation where it's like,
let's not forget about these things because that's how they happen in the first
place.
Let's not be afraid of pain.
Let's not be afraid of our personal pain,
our collective pain.
You know,
what's happening with black lives matters,
black,
black lives matter.
And with everything that's happening in the country with the race,
divide,
the poverty divide with the gay rights movement,
these are all attempts to go,
let's look,
let's really look and deal with the woundedness in the,
in the culture that we've created.
And only then will we start rioting.
And until then we will riot,
um,
peacefully for the most part.
Thank God.
Um,
beautifully.
so yeah,
it's uh,
yeah,
I don't know.
It's awesome.
Um,
well now I feel silly asking about the film details,
but no,
no,
no.
It's one thing to me,
I think we've talked about briefly is this kind of,
again,
it's the wanting more,
it's,
it's also the sense of temptation.
I think Michael Shannon's character is their sense of temptation where he's
like,
I'm going to pray upon the week.
And he's,
he plays the,
a realtor in the film and,
and one of the people who did capitalize on this kind of crazy housing boom,
and he's still leads these like semi glamorous life.
And I think your character definitely kind of falls into that.
So what was it like working,
you know,
working with him on that?
Um,
yeah.
well he's a powerful presence.
Um,
so it was great.
It was really challenging for me,
uh,
to play with him.
You know,
it's like I love,
I,
I struggle to play ping pong with people who are not as good as me.
Um,
I don't play very well,
but when someone's better than me,
I really like I find,
I find,
I find things that I didn't know I can do it.
So I love that.
I love being pushed in that way.
So He of course he's this brilliant that goes for Laura Dunn and Norma Lomax as
well,
you know.
Um,
so doing that with,
with Michael specifically was awesome and the complexity of it because no one's
happy.
He's not happy.
The guy that has it all.
And then Susan and then some,
and once more has,
is,
is trying to fill a bucket with a hole in the bottom of it with stuff.
And as we all know,
and I'm,
I forget a lot of the time,
is that stuff is not gonna fill that,
that void.
Um,
uh,
status,
power,
money,
all the fame rich,
like the riches.
That's,
that's,
that's the mirror.
That's the American dream stuff.
The really kind of gets in the way of,
of,
um,
of the stuff actually feeds us.
It's,
um,
it's,
it's Mcdonald's stuff.
It's a,
yeah,
it's kind of making us sicker.
Um,
so,
and I think what Michael Does so brilliantly is he expresses that in a very
subtle way and you kind of,
he gives a wink,
he just kind of says he's asking to be saved himself.
So if we,
if we can all find it in our hearts to,
um,
to somehow remember the Donald Trump is asking for saving from his own greed
and,
um,
insanity,
then I,
I think,
uh,
um,
we,
we can really,
we can really rescue him from himself.
Um,
but that,
but that's the thing is like,
it was lost.
Like even like,
I don't think,
I don't think the system as it stands is serving either,
neither party.
Everyone's in prison.
In some way,
you know,
um,
the,
the 1% of the world are imprisoned in the gated communities with barbed wire
fencing around it,
just like those who are in actual penitentiary,
he saw,
you know,
so,
um,
so yeah,
but exploring that was really,
it was really painful and,
and you know,
thank God it was with these kind of great actors.
Um,
well there are two characters who actually kind of reject that vision.
and,
and Lauren and knows characters like your family.
They don't necessarily,
they're satisfied to a degree with,
you know,
what the characters have.
Yeah.
Um,
and there's,
you know,
there's this wonderful moment where we're know who plays her son just rejects,
rejects it all,
and he goes,
he doesn't want that.
He wants his home.
He can feel he has the,
he has the untarnished spirit that,
that nose.
Oh no,
that's not what this is about.
It doesn't even know it consciously.
It's just that doesn't feel good.
This feels good.
Like,
just being together feels good.
I don't care where we are,
whether we're in a motel,
a house,
the forest,
homeless.
I just want you here.
I just want,
you know,
real community and family and love.
I think,
I think that's absolutely,
but your character does a lot of things for his family,
but I,
you know,
do you,
do you think it's kind of for his family,
but maybe sometimes at their expense and also,
yeah,
it's this kind of like he does,
he doesn't tell them a lot of things.
He's not honest with them,
which creates a divide.
Totally shame.
Yeah.
There's a lot of shame in the behavior that,
that,
that my character is forced into in order to provide.
But then the question arises,
what,
um,
what is that person providing?
Um,
he's definitely not providing a safe home is definitely providing intimacy is
definitely not providing,
um,
a role model of compassion,
empathy and love his providing
a bigger house and a bigger pool and less time with his dad.
And,
uh,
and yeah,
no,
it's interesting and it's,
it is beautiful that,
that the mother and the son,
uh,
you know,
the feminine and the kind of the innocent,
pure,
innocent in the story or the other,
the emotional touchstone,
the kind of the ethical core is held in,
of course the woman because that's just the way of the world,
the Feminine Intelligence.
And then this kind of pure intelligence.
They know this,
this child like vision of the world that,
that just knows,
knows what,
what's warm and knows what's cold and those where he's meant to be.
Yeah.
Um,
I think there's,
I told you I'd bring this up.
There's a,
there's a scene and a moment where he just,
it's this sense of shame and he sinks so low and it's willing to literally
dealing shit too,
you know,
to do what he thinks he needs to do for his,
it's literally,
there's papers.
Um,
literally,
yeah,
I wish I was kidding.
Um,
but it's,
it's heartbreaking and it was really distressing to watch this person,
but also in,
at that point,
it's very inspiring to be like,
you know what?
This person isn't going to ask for a handout,
they're going to do the grossest thing I've seen on film in a while.
Um hmm.
In
order to kind of build this honest life for themselves at that point.
Um,
so what was that like for you?
Just kind of tapping into that moment because for me that was a very pivotal
point.
Um,
you also just say it was gross.
I think what you said is so accurate about he doesn't want handouts.
And the majority of the families that I met while in Florida was totally willing
to work.
They were actually,
in fact desperate to work.
They wanted to be employed.
They weren't,
they were not loafers.
They will not lazy.
They were not looking for handouts.
They were burning up inside because they weren't being given an opportunity to,
um,
to even begin to be a man.
The,
they had been stripped of all dignity in that respect.
Um,
so I think in that moment
there's real weird pride in it.
That's why I experienced it was there was,
it was a real moment of showing up for yourself and saying,
I will shovel shit.
I will,
I will do anything in order to,
to,
to make sure the ones I love have protection and survive.
Um,
and then if we get possible viable,
maybe we'll try and live a little as well.
Um,
so yeah,
no,
that moment was actually a,
a nice turning point for me in terms of filming because I didn't expect it to be
like that.
I expected it to be pretty,
you know,
but this,
but there's some kind of an,
there's some kind of something,
you know,
there's something vital about going into the shit.
You know,
it's,
it's kind of the,
the sadness,
joy thing.
It's like I can't get to the joy unless I really go down.
It's like it was Louis Ck did something on a talk show with,
I think it was with Conan and it was about our small phones.
Did you get,
anyone will see,
and he's talking about,
he's talking about,
um,
the addiction he has to being connected and how he's on the freeway.
And it's,
um,
you know,
there's lots of traffic and he's bored and he gets that little tingle of deep
grief.
So he goes through his phone to try and like see who's liked a picture of his
dog or whatever.
And just to kind of allay that feeling of grief.
And then he caught himself doing it and he pulls over onto the side of the road
and he just stops and he lets himself be with that feeling and the way he says
it is hilarious.
So I'm saying in a very earnest and sincere way,
so I'm sorry.
So just go and look at the Lucy case version after this.
And he's just like,
he just started like bawling.
It just starts like crying his eyes out and it's like this,
like this well of grief that he hadn't been in tune with for so long.
And then he,
he,
he said he felt this genuine sense of like pure joy,
real joy and not the of joy that comes from someone liking a dog picture.
Um,
yeah.
So it's that,
it was that for me,
it was like I just cleaned fucking shit.
And now I get to go home and play with my son.
Like that's what the feeling was.
I think it's kind of earning those emotions,
you know,
earning,
earning the highs by going through the list,
singing for your supper as they say.
Yeah.
Um,
so we'll take audience questions in a moment if anyone wants to line up.
Uh,
so I mean,
what would you say was by what was the most challenging part of this role?
I mean,
the whole thing itself is,
is clearly
a tough one.
And it took out a big,
big,
big thing to tackle.
But yeah,
the most challenging part,
to be honest,
I think the,
the,
the best Paul and the most challenging part was having had proper time with
families who have been through it and knowing the,
the,
the grief and pain of it so,
so intimately.
And then you go,
oh boy,
how am I going to represent this in a way that's authentic and truthful and
doesn't compromise the experience of these people,
these noble souls that are,
that have their dignity stripped away by the system wherein,
um,
so yeah,
that was really,
yeah,
it was the whole thing really.
Obviously I kind of woke up with that.
Oh Gosh.
Pressure,
beautiful pressure everyday cause it's that pressure kind of provided meaning
for me everyday showing up and it's kind of maybe a responsibility to kind of
represent this as accurately.
Would you say that's also the most rewarding part of this whole,
funnily enough,
there we go.
The,
the the most difficult part is the most rewarding part and them in the deepest
pain.
Is that the highest joy as far as I know.
Yeah.
Thank you.
I'll turn it over to the audience.
Um,
hi.
I like to see a screening of your video of your movie last week and it was
really great.
Um,
there's a lot of emotional scenes.
So what seem do you think was the most challenging for you to film?
Um,
their,
their eviction?
Probably was a
very difficult and,
and it was,
it was,
it was cool.
I mean,
I say cool.
It was really rewarding to,
to shoot the film because remain Barany the,
the,
the director does a lot of work with non actors for the most part.
And I knew that he was going to be,
he was going to be employing nonactors for a lot of the smaller roles when in
the sequence is what I'm,
when I started evicting people,
they were just regular people off the street and some of who had been through
this very thing.
So it was very emotionally visceral and it was just really,
really,
um,
I dunno,
added an element of reality and that life,
it was really cool.
So I,
I kind of said,
well,
if you're going to hire a non actors,
I need to be a non-actor as well.
And I actually,
a lot of it,
like that whole sequence was a totally improvised.
Um,
and Bobby and big house gave a DP kind of just followed us around with his
camera.
And,
uh,
so that was another really rewarding and challenging part was keeping the,
keeping the reality or the story alive because we really didn't use this script
all that.
Thank you.
Hi.
So thank you for coming.
Uh,
so my question is,
you mentioned how it's important to recognize that there are these problems in
our society and you talked about how you visited,
visited these people.
Um,
so I was wondering how,
how do you keep from,
from feeling guilty,
I guess,
about having,
you know,
the things that we do and especially us who work at Google.
I know we have a lot of firsts and um,
and so how do you stay in tune and recognize and have a recognition and
appreciation for these problems without feeling really,
really guilty about what you have yourself?
Yeah.
Wow.
Do you know how,
I know that's why I'm asking you.
Oh,
I was hosting the
maybe some questions about or comments about how you,
how you deal with it.
Yeah.
I just try and ignore it as a smoker.
This like whatever.
Um,
no,
I feel guilty.
I feel really guilty.
I'm a privileged
Glenn and I'm a white male that has happened to be able to make a living from
what he loves to do.
That's insane.
That is,
I know that obviously all of us in this room feel a similar way to that.
So yeah,
that is a,
that is the perfect question.
How do you feel not guilty?
You give,
give yourself two things that,
that are in service of the other,
the origins service.
You don't,
you don't,
you don't change the world.
You don't,
you don't,
I mean,
you can try,
but then you,
you,
you'll fail.
But at least you'll,
you'll do your part.
So it,
so,
yeah.
I guess the question is what do you do with that feeling?
It's not about,
cause I think,
I think I,
I,
I will feel guilty.
I will feel like I'm not doing enough.
I will feel ashamed unless I'm actively putting that feeling into some type of
service for my fellow man.
Some type of giving to and whatever.
Wait,
I'm supposed to,
not in the way of,
you know,
for me it's,
I'm not,
I'm not Martin Luther King.
I'm not gone.
I'm not Russell brand.
Um,
a little bit.
I just read my mind what he's doing a lot.
Actually.
I think he's,
you know,
he's doing,
he's doing his part.
Um,
so I think the idea is we all find our parts,
we all find what part we're supposed to,
we're called to play and it will only we know what that is.
So yeah,
how do we,
how do we do it?
And that's a constant unfolding question and answering in a question again at
all answering,
but I know that I feel a little bit better and be more peaceful when I know I've
given to something meaningful.
Okay.
Thank
you.
Does that help?
Uh,
hi.
I'm again,
thank you for coming and speaking with us.
Um,
yeah,
so,
oh man.
Okay.
My question was similar to hers,
but then she asked that question.
Um,
okay.
So,
uh,
I,
I read that 99 homes is your first film as a producer as well as an actor.
Um,
I was wondering how is,
um,
how was that experience?
Did you find you're able to like
have a greater impact on like the,
the mission of this movie because you were a producer as opposed to an hour?
I hope so.
Um,
I definitely love the film making process and I definitely feel inclined towards
more control.
Um,
cause he doesn't like control.
Right.
Um,
so I,
yeah,
no,
I loved it.
I absolutely loved it.
Um,
and I,
I don't know how I impacted in the film,
but I know that I,
it felt good to be in the conversation constantly with the filmmaker and with
the crew and felt a sense of a more ownership over one doing something as an
actor and you kind of come in,
you do your part and then you leave.
And I don't like that feeling.
It's very,
very different theater and then film because in theater,
the actors or the community,
there's created,
whereas in film crew with the community,
um,
so I kind of miss that a lot when I'm doing what I'm doing film.
But,
um,
but yeah,
it was,
it was great.
And I hope to keep doing it because,
um,
I,
I've,
I've had experiences with,
uh,
powerlessness in,
in,
in the work I've done in,
it hasn't felt all that good.
Like I really like being involved from the ground up.
So yeah,
I felt really good.
Thank you.
Hi.
Thank you for coming.
Um,
I saw the movie and I really enjoyed it.
I was wondering,
so in the movie it seemed like there was a lot of emphasis put on the,
the man's perspective as like breadwinner for the family.
Yeah.
Um,
and in general,
all of the cases that we saw more in depth,
that was the man who is trying to provide for the family and get them out of the
situation.
Um,
and I was wondering how when you visited people in Florida,
um,
if that was generally the case for what you were seeing or if there were some
women who are trying to provide for their families and did that affect it all
the representation of the character of your mother?
Hmm.
Such a good question.
Thank you for,
um,
the,
I mean this is by no means a fast sample that I,
that I was,
uh,
engaged with,
but in the families I met was the,
the,
the male that was the breadwinner for the most part.
And there were a couple of instances where that wasn't true.
Um,
I really love that question.
And uh,
there there is,
uh,
there is a part of the,
of the story of my nine homes where,
you know,
Laura Dunn's carrots and my mother is,
is,
is another source of income with her,
with her house stuff.
Um,
I'm afraid of,
I'm afraid that it's a misrepresentation.
Now that you asked this,
I'm afraid that this,
there's um,
don't miss representation,
but a,
a more limited representation than maybe we,
we,
we could have done.
I really don't know.
I have to,
I have to think about that already.
Thank you for bringing that to my attention.
MMM.
It's,
I mean,
ultimately it's still a film and it is a representation.
If the story that needs to be told I needed to be this family story is film
across,
like that's what it's gonna.
I'm sure be but about one,
one kind of interesting part of it to me was that it was a single father.
Um,
yeah.
Which is an entirely different dynamic that you don't always see.
A lot of times you see,
you know,
it's a single mother and stuff like that,
but this was like a,
yeah,
know,
obviously my mother was,
you know,
in the kind of film right car to his was the breadwinner in the single mother.
And then
that's,
um,
you know,
I can speak to
is,
it's definitely inherent in me.
This,
this old idea and I don't know whether this is learned behavior.
Oh,
okay.
In bread,
um,
uh,
kind of archetypal or of of that masculine energy.
I say masculine energy that lives in men and women,
um,
as just as feminine energy lives in both.
Um,
I know for me as a man and the majority of the men I speak to in that I know
intimately,
there is this pressure self-inflicted science,
saline inflicted,
culturally inflicted,
that says
if you are not providing the money,
the shelter,
the food,
then you're not a man.
That's a fallacy.
Like,
I,
I know that on a very deep instinctive level that that is a fallacy that has no
bearing on manhood.
Um,
and I think one of the things that I was excited to reflect was that pressure in
corner,
that pressure embodied in
the males in our culture and maybe how
that's lost its way a bit and gone a little,
a little crazy,
a little,
um,
kind of,
it's become this beast.
And I,
and I,
and I know growing up,
my father felt that if he wasn't providing,
he was,
you know,
not,
not matching up and a,
and all the men I spoke to her Florida,
it's the same thing.
Um,
yeah,
I,
I really don't know why,
why it's ended up that way and,
uh,
but I'm really interested in your question.
Can you,
can you repeat your question again just to,
just in case I have missed something?
Um,
I,
I think you answered it pretty well,
but I was just asking if,
um,
the representation that men are generally the ones providing for their families
in these cases and trying to get themselves out of these situations of eviction.
Right.
Um,
if that was representative of the cases that you saw and met with in Florida,
and if that played into it all the character of your mother and how,
how she played that part.
Right.
Let me,
I thought thank you for repeating it.
Um,
I then,
as I say that was my experience and doesn't mean that is the general experience
of these families who are going through this specific thing.
I will add add to this that this,
that what Laura Dunn brought to this,
this role.
A lot of it was,
um,
yeah,
unfortunately not,
I'm totally in the film.
Uh hmm.
Um,
and,
and that's a heartbreak for,
for the,
for the filmmaker.
I know because Laura is one of the greatest actors out there and what she
brought was all this complexity and,
and a depth.
And,
um,
so,
so there is,
there are some elements that are missing from the story.
And I'm so happy that you picked up on that because that's why,
hey you saying because it was in,
it's in,
it was in,
well it was that and the experience and there's a phrase,
kill your darlings that,
and then it's applicable here to what the filmmaker has to do.
And ultimately,
you know,
he,
he wanted to focus more on this tension relationship between the realtor and the
evictee.
Um,
so yes,
um,
bomber and a cool,
I'm really glad that you were like,
well,
because that's how I fell in love was where is she?
I want her,
was she up to what you're doing?
And uh,
and I love,
I love where that conversation is going as well.
Um,
and,
and again,
I think of that Nina Simone Song,
Mississippi Goddam and the slowness of change and how frustratingly and angering
the slow
change is in the feminist movement in,
um,
an old progressive movements that need acceleration,
that need the fire.
The,
so thank you and
thank you very much.
I'm with you.
This is what a feminist looks like.
Is that,
is that the right terminology?
The right term?
So I think my last question is,
you know,
this was a wonderful addition to your body of work and you've done such awesome
stage work.
Is there anything like,
what's up next for you?
What do you want to tackle next?
Uh,
this is what my ego gets a little excited talk.
Um,
and I,
I guess worried about that because the ego's tricky.
Um,
anything specific?
I mean,
I know,
um,
uh,
I,
I did a movie recently.
I'm going to do another movie and then I'll do a play.
All right.
How's that?
That's great.
It's the perfect answer,
I have to say.
Sorry,
ego.
Sorry.
I'm not going to,
we're going to give you one little bone that you will not to chew them.
Well,
this is a wonderful film and thank you so much for joining us.
[inaudible].